After space and
color, type is the next item you should
consider when creating a great app.
Roboto, the default sans
serif font family for
Android, is a great place to start,
as it was specifically designed for
user interfaces across
a variety of screens.
Using Roboto gives you the comfort
of knowing your text will work with
a variety of languages and
remain crisp and legible on any screen.
And, you can use Roboto across
your entire app, whether it be for
headlines, body text,
smaller captions or whatever.
It includes a bunch of weights,
like light, regular, medium, bold, and
black, and
variants like condensed and slab.
Having those variants available
in addition to font size and
color let's you clearly communicate, for
example, what's a headline versus
what's part of the body text.
Or, as we sometimes say, it'll help
you establish a clear hierarchy for
the text in your app.
Now, typography is a really large topic,
and we'll
try to fit as much as possible into this
course, but we can only cover so much.
If you're interested in typography
outside the realm of mobile app design,
I strongly encourage you to
check out some of the books
linked in the instructor notes.
There's a whole world of information
out there if you're a typography
fanatic like me.